build-it dry plant Vsauce this is your
home for some of the coolest creations
from everyday people
this is bdp building artists Kyle our me
makes hand carved landscapes out of
books
he says mountains of disused knowledge
return to what they really are
Mountains some of his projects include
han-shan the cave the Great Wall and a
dew made from an encyclopedia britannica
set Eric Hart built a replica of the
Game of Thrones chest given to Daenerys
in season 1 he has step-by-step
instructions on what he did throughout
the build process and he condensed
months of work into a seven minute video
showcasing his creation sculptor Liu
schwack created these hybrid animal and
human sculptures each piece features a
human head in some sort of animal
appendage and they explore the ideas of
physical beauty including this man and
pig woman and a chicken man and dog and
this man horse professional origami
artist seafoam abana intends to build a
life-sized elephant to prove that a
simple piece of paper can be transformed
into anything imaginable with the help
of three assistants the giant paper
elephant will be made out of a sheet
measuring 15 by 15 meters and the final
project will stand over three meters
tall drawn QWERTY is a project by artist
Pablo Gamboa Santos that superimposes
typed letters of an old typewriter to
create landscapes he has more than 300
creations and they make up a 60 meter
long mural of some simple designs and
some that are more intricate Joma
Montserrat has an unraveling animal
series called empty land that combines
different species intertwined like this
owl and kangaroo tiger and cheetah
penguin and rabbit bear and Fox and
zebra snake and now for the
hyper-realistic pencil drawings of Diego
Fazio
spy creates humorous and
thought-provoking street art that he
says are filled with equal parts of
irony and positive humor his project
cameras involved installing 150 fake
cameras on a building facade with the
intention of watching over nothing plan
for those who see is a project by Daniel
Schultz that uses a 7x7 grid of speakers
to shoot rings of fog and help visualize
sound Alan Silvestri performs a
beautiful acoustic rendition of back to
the future
Vsauce fan
Daniel ferry is a one-man band here's
his version of madness by muse
three
finally here's the official video for
I'm Aquarius by Metronomy directed by
Edouard Salyer so make your B DPS as a
personal message here on YouTube or
share them with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to only your creations and as
always thanks for watching